his first goblin to bring up on stage
though he is a funny up and coming stand
up liv's right here in austin you might
have seen him he's a regular on the kill
tony podcast give it up for my friend mr
hans kim
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and i'm very gender fluid so please
respect my pronouns
i'm biologically male but my bullies
identify me as a [ __ ]
so you have to respect me
i am very sexually active right now if
you couldn't tell
uh dating this woman who was really into
yoga and choke sex
i was like do you enjoy breathing or not
i hope you're my millennial
but uh good to be here i uh i love being
here in texas because i'm also a
summoner or from south korea
there's only two things i like shooting
commies in k-pop
i'm one of you guys
i gotta be punished by my asian friends
a lot which is very hurtful they make
fun of me because i like to eat panda
express
they're like hey huh doesn't panda
express just a shitty americanized
version of something authentically asian
i was like yeah but so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour 3.
i love being asian because whenever i
walk into starbucks i can tell them that
my name is ching chong bing bang the
third
what are they gonna do
hey that's not your name
excuse me skyler
i come from a long line of big bonds
i love being asian but you know racism
is so very tough on me um
like most people were racists don't even
realize how racist they really are like
this one guy comes up to me and he just
starts going like tokyo
i was like dude just as i look like this
it may speak your goof language
and the post office is right there
[Applause]
i think it's kind of [ __ ] up how the
first thing that americans made asians
do when we came over here is to build
railroads and now you guys aren't even
using that [ __ ] anymore
you ever wonder why we're so bad at
driving we were all in on the railroad
game
switched it up on us
um it's uh
pretty cool to be asian whenever someone
is racist to me i'm just like oh you
hate respectful people who keep to
themselves
okay good luck finding an affordable car
i'm trying really hard
it's hard to date as an asian man
everyone thinks asian women are way
sexier but how do you think asian women
are created
me [ __ ]
i'm a crucial part of the sexy process
please stop trying to scare me
if you have sex with me your children
will be very beautiful
half of them
the other half will be great engineers
and that's important
i feel like a lot of
white women are intimidated to date
asian men because we are technically the
perfect woman
i have less confidence than you i'm
better being told what to do i don't
have to shave as much
pretty much
the hottest girl ever
go [ __ ] me all at once
i'm not a big fan of asian women because
they act like they're hotter than asian
men but we look exactly the same [ __ ]
[Applause]
i could throw on a wig at bf7 relax
why are you pregnant you can [ __ ] white
dudes
i can [ __ ] white dudes
they're the most perverted people ever
because
of white dudes
i know
in america asian women are hot but don't
forget back home we're throwing you away
stay humble
my uh my sister is pretty cool she just
got back from a mission trip if you
don't know what that is that's where
americans go to third world countries to
get new profile pictures
she was like did you know that your
toilet water is cleaner than the
drinking water in africa
i was like these are the pipes that we
have what do you want me to do about it
if i see an african walking down the
street i'll let them drink from my
toilet
it's not a problem
just flush afterwards i don't want to
get aids
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm not a racist
i'm a minority how could i be
i don't even see race i only smell it
especially in those ubers
i love uh
i love all the different races you know
but i was on an airplane and i saw a
dude reading a book in arabic which kind
of freaked me out
but then i saw him fold the corner of
the page and put the book away and i was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
[Music]
[Laughter]
happy ending
that story
my favorite movie is the black panther
movie because it gave black children a
hero they could look up to
and not just someone like martha king jr
malcolm x or harriet tubman or thurgood
marshall and georgia carver
maya angelou rosa parks nelson mandela
[Music]
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat
he's got a little cat ears what is he an
asian school girl
what are they gonna come out with a
yellow panda huh what the [ __ ]
um
good to be here i love uh being here in
the south because i think rednecks are
crazy rednecks can survive in any
wilderness situation that you put them
in
except the situation where everyone has
equal rights
that kind of [ __ ] them up
you can live in a swamp with an
alligator why can't you live in a
cul-de-sac with a minority
i think it's funny that tanner is a
white person's name
[Music]
better than what
it should be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner
that's my black friend tannis
[Laughter]
it's the suffix joke
i love the whites i think having a white
pride is pretty cool but a lot of people
do it incorrectly they're always into
like the nazis they're like slavery
they're never into like building a
castle or yodling
[Applause]
that's not white pride that's racism
you don't have to be white to hate the
jews
i can do that too
i know but i could
um i don't hate the jews i grew up
christian as an asian person which is
kind of weird because the people wrote
the bible didn't mean to know that
asians existed
they couldn't even drop us a line
hey asians great job on inventing the
compass
and fireworks
anyways back to the jews my favorites
oh [ __ ] things about the goddamn jews
we're great people
um don't hate the jews
i am an atheist now because i'm not in
kindergarten and i have an internet
connection
i think it'd be stressful to have an
ideology that can be destroyed by facts
he's just walking down the street oh
look apostle [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i guess i could have been blowing dudes
this whole time
i'm not gay i love ladies i think they
are the sexiest janitor generous
genitals
[Music]
gender the sexiest gender in the human
race
definitely the top 27.
ladies gonna make the sweet 16 this year
um i don't think i could ever [ __ ] a
dude sorry fellas especially this guy
sorry man
i i've never looked at a beautiful woman
i've been like wow is there a version of
her that's bigger and hairier
has less kindness
i want to stick with that in my butthole
straight as [ __ ]
please leave me my dad
[Laughter]
my dad's like it would suck to be gay
that would suck can you imagine if
you're gay that means most of the gender
that you're attracted to wouldn't be
attracted to you back
and i was like whoa
can't even imagine
they must cry and masturbate a lot
just a guess
i do love the ladies my friends are
always giving me dating advice they're
like do you need to learn how to talk to
women
maybe or maybe women should learn how to
listen to hans
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
or the party come on it's fun
um this one lady was like did you know
that my vagina is a 3d printer because
it can make a baby
a you know 3d printer
uh i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer your vagina is the tray
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
[Music]
it takes nine months to print
and the whole time it's printing is
complaining
needless to say i did not see any trays
at night
[Music]
i am happy that women give birth because
i feel like if men gave birth we'd be
like bro i've been eating so much
protein in creatine during my pregnancy
this baby's like 27 pounds already bro
so about those gains in the first
trimester
i uh
i love dating you know it's kind of
tough for me though because 99 of my sex
career was sobo
and
now i have to have an orgasm when
someone's [ __ ] on my glasses
i know what my name is you don't have to
keep saying it
where's my office chair i'm gonna come
a lot of ladies call me a premature
ejaculator which hurts my feelings
because premature to who
i came right at the perfect time when i
felt amazing
it takes the training how to please
yourself lady
i am uh sapiosexual that means i'm
looking for a girlfriend who is
intellectually stimulated by the mental
exercise of finding me attractive
i've always
um i love uh the sayings in english i
love how people say in prison don't drop
the soap
i think it should be don't pick up the
soap
you can drop as much soap as you want
as the bending over when they really get
you
even if you don't drop the soap you're
still gonna get raped
you're just gonna have really clean
hands what happens
who are these prisoners like man i want
to get that kid but he never drops a
soap
does he have a butthole we'll never know
all right that's my thought thank you
guys very much
thank you guys so much for coming to the
best comedy show in the world
uh this next comic is a living legend
and a comedy
master please get up for austin's own
ron white
[Applause]